near liam burns i think many people will
remember was the mp um that wrote that
note um that the tories have used ever
since to condemn labour's record with
the economy and he left note for after
um gordon brown left office saying i'm
afraid there's no money a lot of people
will remember
him for that but today the independent
expert panel have recommended that he be
suspended from the house of commons for
two days for breaching their rules on
bullying and harassment they said that
he had abused his position of power by
uh ostracizing the complainant by
denying them access their parliamentary
system
and by ceasing contact with them for a
number of months during lockdown and
we've had a response
from liam byrne in the last
couple of minutes he says i did not
resolve the dispute correctly with a
proper disciplinary process and he said
that his actions constituted an
ostracism which was a breach of
parliament's behavioural code which i
strongly support and cause distress for
which i am profoundly sorry i have
apologized in full to the individual
concerned